hablamos de salud en directo américa de
france 24 y marina sardinas ya está
conmigo en el estudio marina muy buena
mañana de jueves vamos a volver a hablar
de la llamada viruela del mono porque ya
se han confirmado casos en al menos 29
países marina donde esta enfermedad no
es endémica así de raúl buenos días la
organización mundial de la salud ya ha
registrado más de 1000 casos confirmados
en países donde esta enfermedad no es
endémica en 29 países concretamente
principalmente la mayoría se han
registrado en europa y eeuu pero
recordemos también que esta enfermedad
si es endémica desde hace varias décadas
en varias naciones de áfrica occidental
y central y que saltó al norte global el
pasado mayo principalmente a finales de
mayo cuando se detectó este primer caso
positivo veamos en el siguiente mapa la
distribución de cómo están los casos
como decíamos ayer eeuu y europa es
donde se registran la mayoría de los
contagios de la viruela del mono pero
también en américa latina' méxico y
argentina que han confirmado los
primeros casos de este virus también
brasil brasil está estudiando
recientemente el 1er de un hombre que
habría viajado a españa recientemente a
diferencia del continente africano donde
si en este año ya se han registrado 66
decesos en estas naciones de occidente
todavía no se han registrado ningún
fallecimiento pero sin embargo pues la
o&m se está alertando sobre esta está
transmisión del virus esto fue lo que
dijo el director
los principales impulsores de la
propagación de este virus en este
momento en el entorno no endémico son
cara a cara que la piel personal
contacto interpersonal contacto físico
en a tu momento de ver en este momento
todavía hay una ventana de oportunidad
para prevenir la propagación de la vibra
del mono en aquellos que están en mayor
riesgo hi stress right now marina
continuamos con nuestra crónica porque
ante esta provocación algunos países ya
han comenzado la vacunación contra esta
viruela no si a medida que los casos
aumentan raúl también los científicos
debaten cuál es la mejor estrategia para
combatir esta enfermedad algunas
naciones como eeuu reino unido canadá o
recientemente alemania están
implementando la estrategia llamada
vacunación en anillo que en qué consiste
bueno se trata de vacunar a aquellas
personas que están en riesgo por ejemplo
hombres que han tenido sexo con hombres
o personal sanitario que está en esta
primera línea de batalla contra esta
enfermedad y que han estado pues en
contacto con la viruela lo que
recomiendan es que se administre la
vacuna entre los 4 y 14 días posteriores
a su exposición esta campaña de
vacunación
o si es apoyada por la o ms que todavía
raúl no recomienda una vacunación masiva
de contra esta enfermedad
también el organismo está coordinando la
distribución de vacunas antivirales para
las personas más vulnerables a través de
las reservas que tienen y que se
encuentran principalmente en países
donde esta enfermedad no es endémica
pero como decimos pues sin embargo la
mayoría de casos como veíamos
anteriormente en el gráfico se
encuentran en países de áfrica donde si
es endémica esta enfermedad también y
ahora lo que están diciendo es si esta
vacunación es efectiva y hay que hacer
como una especie de seguimiento también
un monitoreo para ver si realmente
funcionan y si existen pues también
suficientes vacunas teniendo en cuenta
lo que decíamos que el almacenamiento de
estas dosis está en países de occidente
no en los países donde la enfermedad es
endémica marina le quiero preguntar
entonces si esta vida del mono se podría
transmitir también por aire finalmente
bueno esto raúl si tenemos que recordar
que la principal vía de transmisión no
es por aire no pero sí que se está
investigando y están empezando a salir
los primeros informes sobre si es
posible que ésta la enfermedad se
transmite a través de partículas
contenidas en el aire también recordemos
que la enfermedad se transmite por la
sangre por líquidos corporales por
lesiones en la piel o en contacto con
mucosas de animales que están infectados
pero es cierto también que la forma en
la que este brote se está propagando
pues al general generado incógnitas
dentro de la comunidad científica
hace algunos recientemente en los
centros para el control y la prevención
de enfermedades de eeuu hicieron una
recomendación de portar mascarillas a
los viajeros que viajaran a países donde
esta enfermedad estuviera en transmisión
una recomendación que luego eliminaron
puesto que sonaba un poco alarmista y no
querían tampoco alarmar porque todavía
esta transmisión a través de partículas
contenidas en el aire está en
investigación también sin embargo pues
sí que lanzaron la advertencia de que se
puede transmitir a través del aire pero
en un es contacto muy estrecho
y prolongado en el tiempo
esto ocurre si realmente pues eso el
contacto es estrecho sin embargo la bbc
pues no ha confirmado todavía esta
posibilidad y quedan muchas incógnitas y
preguntas sobre si la viruela del mono
pues algunas de ellas como por ejemplo
si el brote que este brote no ha sido
tan grave como los anteriores o los que
se vieron en áfrica por tiene un
accidente como decimos no ha causado
decesos pues por qué es tan leve o
también se desconoce si el patógeno se
puede transmitir sin que la persona
presente síntomas o por ejemplo sale un
estudio recientemente de mujeres
embarazadas que transmitían la
enfermedad de este patógeno a sus fetos
como decimos se necesita todavía mucha
investigación al respecto
así es marina entonces vamos a cambiar
ahora de tema para hablar de el
coronavirus porque moderna está
trabajando en una nueva versión de su
vacuna contra el coi 19 de qué se
trataba con unas mujeres tan fuerte la
misma cura nunca esa vacuna ellos mismos
si esa es una nueva vacuna que
laboratorio moderna estaría investigando
para ver si esta investigación está pero
enfocada en el virus de del cómic 19
conocidas pero la variante de omicron o
supuestamente esta vacuna sería hasta
ocho veces aumentaría hasta ocho veces
los niveles de anticuerpos contra la
variante o micro durante las cuatro
primeras semanas de su inoculación se
trata de un ensayo que están 2 y 3 pero
la farmacéutica pues busca poder
distribuir esta vacuna de refuerzo de
cara a la temporada de otoño que viene
en europa estas dosis combinan 25
microgramos de la vacuna original de
moderna con otros 25 de la nueva
dirigida específicamente a esta variante
omicron que es la que está reinando
ahora mismo en todo el mundo marina como
siempre muchísimas gracias por toda la
información en esta sección de salud nos
vemos mañana con más pasamos a saludar a
nuestra segunda invitada del día